hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I am so excited because this is
the moment that I have been waiting for
and I think it's a moment that some of
you have been waiting for as well I now
have my new iPhone 8 plus and this one
actually isn't mine but I am unboxing
this one as well this is the silver
iPhone 8 so one of my favorite things
about the gold iPhone 8 plus so far is
the box is also a very light beige color
you might not be able to tell unless you
hold the other one up to it it's a very
very slight tint let's start the
unboxing trying to contain my excitement
as some of you might think that I'm
overreacting into you I say I am NOT
this is someone who is genuinely
enthusiastic about iPhones and
everything Apple
I need the stickers out of their back
okay but we gotta get my stickers I have
to save my stickers I cannot lose them
hey Motorola do you guys want to use
this enthusiastic face next time you
parody one of my videos for your
commercials I'd say call me but I'm a
little busy yeah I don't want to take it
out of the box it just looks so pristine
and perfect let's open up the silver oh
[Music]
shoot I got so excited for the big
reveal that I forgot instructions better
put this away
all our accessories just came right out
with it we've got our charging brick I
usually use the bigger charging bricks
because they charge my phone much faster
got our ear pods and also we cannot
forget the wonderful infamous dongle if
you don't know what that's for
I just can't talk about it and of course
last but not least we've got a lightning
cable I'm still surprised they didn't
end up going type USBC on the iPhone 10
I thought for sure that they would but I
feel like it may have been a little bit
too much we removed your headphone jack
your touch ID and now you have to unlock
your phone using facial recognition oh
by the way now you need a whole nother
cable all those lightning cables you've
got bye-bye
we've been perfectly fine with it though
because I've got so many USB C cables a
good thing this thing is waterproof I'm
very very excited why don't you want to
take the bottom in Wow
now for the front I cannot stress to you
how beautiful this gold is if you're a
fan of rose gold jewelry this is
definitely something that matches actual
rose gold jewelry the other two golds
that they had the one was too pink the
other was too gold but this is I've said
it before but this is a perfect marriage
of both of those goals to this here's my
pink sand band to kind of go with it
it's a pretty good match here's my pink
sand iPhone case now let's see how this
looks on it because this is what I was
hoping I was hoping that it would look
perfect and it does it's the color
matches almost perfectly and it looks
really really good there's a slight gold
accent right here on the touch ID we've
got our lightning port as usual it looks
really good this almost makes me really
sad that there's not going to be a gold
iPhone 10 if you have an iPhone iPad and
bring it in your by to sign it on
if you want you can also I've never done
this before
quick start a little prompt just showed
up it's saying set up new phone and then
I'm gonna hit continue and we're gonna
see what happens so during the setup it
brings you to this true tone display
setting the iPhone automatically adapts
to ambient lighting conditions to make
colors of your consistently different
environments next up we've got this
little guy we've got all of our same
accessories this is kind of giving me a
little taste of what to expect with the
iPhone 10 because I do plan on getting
the silver estimated time remaining oh
boy who's gonna take a while oh just
kidding
5 minutes 12 10 9 oh I don't know I'll
be patient the silver is really really
great so in comparison to the gold let's
take a look
so looks like all of my apps are being
read downloaded which is probably gonna
take a little while for sure smell those
download I have two other cases to show
you guys here this is a rose red color
and I know you guys know that I'm not a
huge fan of red but this is more like a
berry type color so it's not necessarily
ready I feel like if I was gonna have a
red case this is definitely the color
that I would go for see what it looks
like
on me silver eight always curious what
do you guys prefer do you prefer our
smaller phone
do you like the 8 + do you like the size
of the age or do you even think that
this is too big I've also got one of the
new iPhone 8 leather cases this is the
cosmos blue seem to
why are you so difficult oh this is
actually a nice color blue see Matt the
blue it looks like on the gold phone
it's not bad I don't think that I would
pair this blue with the gold though you
would probably go very well with the
white I'm sure it would look perfectly
fine also on the black it's not bad I
feel like this is not a justine color
though i might try to go caseless for a
little while I know that's very very
scary one thing I thought was kind of
interesting is they removed all of the
text below the iPhone so as you can see
there's text here no text here very very
clean here are some of the new
wallpapers I think I'm probably going to
choose I already have one of these sets
which I previously had downloaded
whenever they had the leaked images I
think this one here's a look at some of
the new camera features we've got the
natural light the studio light contour
light stage light stage light mono I'm
wondering if I'm gonna be able to try to
take a picture of myself place a subject
within stage light okay the struggle of
making videos by myself I don't have
anybody to take this picture for me this
is gonna be a great test let's see here
I feel like that what I might be in okay
let's just let's press the button as you
would have
okay I just took this picture basically
and just set up a timer and took a
picture of myself very dramatic oh yeah
this is definitely gonna work way better
you want to have somebody else take the
picture for me
I'll be doing a full camera review and
test very very shortly so look for that
in the next couple of days there may be
a chance the videos already up and be
sure to check my channel and make sure
you subscribe so you know when I launch
new videos my phone is still currently
updating so there it is I need to be
much further away I can't reach my arm
and further
[Music]
one of the big highlights of the new 8
in the 8 plus is bear is now wireless
charging I covered these chargers in my
previous video where I opened some
accessories for my new iPhone and my
Apple watch this is the multi charger
and this is the Belkin wireless charger
and if you're completely clueless on how
this works you may have missed that
demonstration well thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this unboxing of the new iPhone
8 plus in gold and the silver 8 I'll be
doing a much more comprehensive review
especially dedicating a lot of time to
the camera but that's something that I'm
not able to film by myself so I'll be
recruiting my sister once again who
actually unbox the iPhone before me she
got the Space Gray which I'm very happy
about so we'll be able to do a color
comparison so look for that video soon
but the next one that I'm going to be
posting is the Apple watch series 3
unboxing I got the gray ceramic and the
white ceramic and I'm not sure which one
I want to keep but I guess we'll find
out buy a box set thanks for watching
and I'll see you guys soon your sleep
just getting a really fine
[Music]